foreign
good afternoon this is business live
with Ian King now the chancellor has
unveiled what he hopes will be some of
the most significant pensions reforms in
decades Jeremy Hunt has reached what he
called a compact with nine of the UK's
leading pension providers including
legal in general and Aviva to commit
five percent of so-called default funds
for defined contribution pension Savers
to unlisted equities by the end of the
decade the chancellor believes the deal
could unlock up to 50 billion pounds
worth of investment if all such UK
pension providers follow suit
the reforms that I'm announcing today
for the average person could unlock an
extra thousand pounds a year on the
value of their pension and it does that
by removing the barriers that currently
stop British Pension funds investing in
some of our most promising fastest
growing companies like the company I'm
at today
what happens at the moment is that these
brilliant British companies are invested
in by Canadian Pension funds Australian
Pension funds but British Pension funds
find they can't and so we're not forcing
anyone to invest anywhere they don't
want to invest but we want to remove the
barriers so that they can have a more
balanced portfolio and therefore
increase the returns to their own
pension fund holders
foreign
speaking at the mansion house which is
of course the official residence of the
Lord mayor of London Nicholas Lyons who
had called for many of the measures the
chancellor outlined I've been speaking
with him
very much so yes I think it was a really
wonderful example of how the long-term
saving savings industry came together
working with the government and
Regulators to come up with a package
that is really going to make a
difference to pension Savers and
hopefully also to UK growth companies
you did of course want an element of
compulsion here which the chancellor has
shied away from no no you challenged me
on that one last time and again I
um I pushed back I'd always said that
there is there are a range of ways to
tackle this and the best way is to try
and do it voluntarily and that's what
we've got to here which is terrific
that's the British way of doing things
so I think we what we do want to see is
a significant investment in
unlisted Equity that will significantly
enhance returns for pension Savers and
by having the nine largest players in
the pension Market representing
two-thirds of DC pensions voluntarily is
saying that this is something that they
agreed to and will commit to I think is
a very strong signal you're not bothered
that some of the major players in the
industry the likes of fidelity haven't
signed up to this compact no I mean we
went to we went to the nine largest
players and said and you know they're
going to be a lot of subsequent ones who
will be follow on ones these are sort of
founder signatories at the end of the
day when you're trying to get a large
number of private sector firms to form a
compact you have to sort of pick pick a
sensible number
now the Chancellor's also announced
plans to potentially roll back on method
2 which of course obliged Brokers to
sell their research rather than bundle
it in with other services is that a good
idea
look I think we need
we need if we're going to create a
really vibrant Equity culture there are
lots of things that we need to do one of
those things is to encourage very strong
equity research and Method 2 was an
obstacle it's not the only obstacle at
the end of the day the decision that
will really drive a step up in the
quality of equity research particularly
around technology stocks will be when
investment Banks feel that there's going
to be a proper flow of IPOs that will
justify spending the money on Research
so that's what we've got to get to this
is a sort of a catalyst for changing the
ecosystem do you worry though that mifid
2 the damage has already been done I
mean there's a real dearth of research
around a lot of small cap companies in
particular now
I think that there the there is we've
got we've got a way to travel
but you know can we get there yes we
certainly can but I think this is one of
uh what will be a series of initiatives
that will really help to shape London as
a listing venue that's really important
if we can stimulate London as a as a
venue for Equity trading and listing of
stocks then we're going to get that
research how rapidly do you think these
measures will have an impact
I I think it will what we've consciously
done is to say we want people to get to
a five percent of DC pensions in
unlisted equities by 2030 because they
need to make that transition gradually
we're not going to be able to invest the
money I mean we're talking about 50
billion pounds by 2030 potentially five
percent of what we think will be in the
DC Market which should be a trillion
pounds by 2030. so we need to it'll take
us a year to to to put together a
collective fund like the future growth
fund you know we've already got legal in
general of Eva and m g with the
capability to do this and they're
already doing it so there are some
options out there but we need
significantly to change and enhance the
scope of what we're doing
well the so-called mansion house
compacts was part of a broader sweep of
changes announced by the chancellor to
stimulate returns for pension Savers and
make the UK economy more productive
other measures include allowing smaller
defined benefit or so-called final
salary pension schemes to merge
encouraging more local Authority pension
schemes to pull their assets and invest
more in private equity and introducing a
so-called Superfund regulatory regime
well joining me now to talk about this
is the former pensions Minister Steve
Webb now a partner at the pensions and
investment firm LCP Steve good to see
you this afternoon let's start with
these proposals for the for the ppf the
light both scheme I mean essentially the
government sees this as perhaps being
allowed to take over schemes that
haven't failed is that a good idea in
your view so there's two very different
pension protection fund ideas kicking
around so the Tony Blair Institute came
up with this idea of saying you take the
small schemes who as you say wouldn't be
in the ppf until the sponsor went bust
and you say there's ridiculous thousands
and thousands of these tiny schemes
let's shove them all in one place where
shall we put them pension protection
fund they've invested well over the
years that would somehow be better and
it looks good on paper and then you
think well hang on a minute but are
these funds well funded in which case
they'll probably go off to an insurer so
they're probably a bit underfunded so
they move to the ppf still get all the
pensions paid in full so who's making up
the shortfall and I don't think we've
got an answer for that question yet so
it looks neat it's just like moving
money from your current account to your
joint account but pensions didn't like
that and isn't the problem though all
these defined benefit schemes they're
all in runoff by definition all they're
trying to do is uh meet the liabilities
that they're due to bad in future
they're not necessarily going for out
and out growth
there's no incentive to at the moment
and so the the proposition that we've
come up with is for the other end of the
scale the big well-funded schemes you
know you think of companies that are
billions of pounds of schemes in Surplus
you know seven years ago took all these
teams together they were 400 billion
pounds in deficit on the same measure
that 400 billion in Surplus today and
the thinking the regulations just hasn't
caught up with this world of surplus so
yeah some will buy out they'll go to
insurer they'll write a check job done
but if you've spent years painstakingly
building up billions of pounds in
pensions why wouldn't you want the
upside why do you want to hand it over
to an insurer so what we're suggesting
is a change to the regime that would
allow these firms to invest for growth
the pension schemes to invest for growth
with some safety underpinning for the
member benefits and then everybody
benefits and that would be overseen by
the ppf in your eyes that's right so at
the moment the pension protection fund
is a Lifeboat so if the company goes
bust the ppf picks up 85 to 95 of the
benefits depending what we're suggesting
is a ppf sub for Levy an opt-in for
well-funded schemes the employer comes
along says I'll pay a bit extra
the member benefits are then fully
underpinned the trustee can see the
member benefits going to be paid so the
trustee can relax and then you can
invest for a bit more growth not a 230a
doc but you know instead of having
everything in Guilds a bit more growth
and then if that creates some surplus
funds The Firm can have some of that the
DB members can have some of that the
younger workers can have some of that
you know there's a bigger pie to carve
up but at the moment we are wasting
billions of pounds and you'd be happy
with five percent of that being
allocated to private Equity or Venture
Capital well the five percent is a is a
DC thing it's about a voluntary thing on
the defined contribution side if the
trustees thought that was a sensible way
of using the money I wouldn't have a
problem with that I'm not a great fan of
arbitrary figures
um but you know if they can invest a bit
more for growth and that's part of the
portfolio why not because that's the
other interesting thing I mean while
we're talking about DB schemes I mean
the Mr Hunt wants local Authority
pension schemes to invest 10 of their
Assets in in this particular class is
that a good idea well I over the years
the the good thing has been local
government schemes coming together I
mean she's incredible we have a Devon
pension scheme and a call more pension
scheme and some you know they're hard to
think they need their own investment
strategy so bringing them together I
think makes sense I I I think there
comes a point Beyond which you say well
why wouldn't the trustees do this anyway
if it was a good idea and to be fair the
government are trying to work out while
other trustees ill-informed are they
risk-averse you know can we are there
barriers fine let's get rid of the
barriers but then let them choose the
right things to invest in not just pick
a number I guess the advantage is though
that these local Authority schemes are
ultimately underwritten by the
government so there is a bit of scope
for a bit more risk-taking there isn't
that much more long-term you know
because you're not worried that they're
not going to be around tomorrow to stand
behind them so they are they are open
they are long-term so they ought to be
investing more for growth so you can see
why they should have a higher allocation
whether 10 is the right number I mean
there is an issue on the supply side of
all of this as well plenty of Trustees
have said to me we'd love to invest in
this stuff where is it what is it you
know so some of these reviews last night
are about the British Business Bank for
example thinking about do they need
another investment vehicle to match make
between the schemes and the people in
investing and do you see these local
government schemes coming together in
the way that the chancellor seems to
want them to
I think the government is so obsessed
with consolidation and scale that they
think six or I think that's how many
there are at the moment is too many so I
could see them pushing them further
together yeah you're always taking on
vested interests so you know people are
going to lose their jobs out of this you
know it's a bit like emerging police
constabularies I guess well that's what
happened in the Netherlands I mean the
the there was massive consolidation and
the whole I mean the sector alignment of
consultancy shrank considerably because
there were just far fewer schemes so
pension schemes shouldn't be a make work
for for the industry but there is a
there are risks there does come a point
where you can be too big there's too
much concentration of risk and at the
moment the drive is entirely in One
Direction worth making them Patrick
Hoskin made an excellent point in the
times today where he said Mr Hunt was
making all sorts of claims for the
returns that these private Investments
are going to make that you'd never be
allowed to make if you were selling an
insurance policy yeah I think they've
been determined to link this kind of
quite high-tech complicated regulatory
City stuff to real people and real
voters one day so that sense the
thousand pound a year on your pension
but the language is very if this then
that you know if they got as good a
return as the best schemes then this
would be the outcome not that it
actually will be
um but I guess trying to make it real to
people because getting people to engage
with pensions as we know is a bit of a
challenge but I mean on on the whole how
many marks out of ten would you give the
chancellor for trying trying to at least
give productivity a boost yeah I'd be in
the seven or eight category because I
think although this is a bit of a
blunderbuss I mean you still haven't
read all the documents they published at
seven o'clock this morning you know got
to do that tonight with a stiff drink
um but you know some of these things
will land some of them will stimulate
sectors that have struggled in the past
I think they've tried to look
holistically and that's probably going
to be a good thing all right Steve well
I'll let you get back to the uh
documentation on your stiff drink good
to see you thank you
some other stories for you now and wages
continue to grow at a record Pace during
the three months to May maintaining
pressure on the bank of England to
continue raising interest rates the
office for National statistics said that
regular average pay which excludes
bonuses grew an annual rate of 7.3
percent that was unchanged from the
three months to the end of April well
private sector paid during the period
Rose by some 7.7 percent that was the
largest outside the pandemic period
while in the public sector it grew by
5.8 percent which was the fastest Pace
since the period from September to
November 2001. but the unemployment rate
unexpectedly Rose from 3.8 percent to
four percent
centracur said today it has struck a
long-term Salem purchase agreement to
buy a million tons a year of liquefied
natural gas from the United States the
owner of British gas said the eight
billion dollar deal with Delphin
Midstream which will run for 15 years
marked an additional move bite to build
further resilience in the UK's energy
security the company has already struck
a three-year Supply agreement with the
Norwegian company Equinox that will heat
four and a half million UK homes through
2024 and it has reopened the rough gas
storage facility which now provides half
of the UK's total gas storage capacity
centrica said today's agreement could
provide enough energy to eat five
percent of UK homes for 15 years
the commercial property firm British
land whose assets include the broad gate
center in the city the Meadow Hall
Shopping Center in South Yorkshire and
the Drake circus Shopping Center in
Plymouth insisted this morning that its
business was continuing to build
momentum despite the uncertain economic
backdrop the company which is the
largest direct owner and operator of
retail parks in the UK said that at
least just over half a million square
feet of space during the three months to
the end of June and that a further 1.2
million square feet had been put under
offer British land said its occupancy
rate was 96 During the period the shares
are up by one and three quarter percent
now the average two-year fixed mortgage
rate has climbed above the level seen
last year when financial markets were
put into turmoil following the so-called
mini budget presented by the then
Chancellor for aussiequarting rates had
been steady earlier this year following
the shock of Mr quasien's proposals but
they've been moving upwards in the last
few months on expectations that the bank
of England has much more work to do to
bring down inflation
well figures released today by analysts
money facts compare showed the average
two-year fixed rate mortgage now stands
at 6.66 percent up from 6.63 yesterday
and that is the highest it's been in 15
years meanwhile the average five-year
fix now stands at 6.17 that's up from
6.13 yesterday there are now almost 300
fewer projects on the market than there
were yesterday as lenders predict
another bank of England rate increase uh
joining me now to talk about this is
Simon Gammon he's founder and managing
partner of the mortgage advisors and
Brokers night Frank Finance Simon good
to see you this afternoon are you seeing
a lot of evidence of homeowners rushing
to lock in mortgage rates yeah
absolutely especially in the last six
weeks I think everyone for the last
since the mini budget people have been
moving thinking rates are coming down
they've been waiting and of course that
hasn't been seen inflation has been
stubborn and so now with rates Rising
people are having to act they don't like
the right rates they're taking but
they're having to act and we've seen a
big spike so these are people that have
come off a fix they've moved on to a
floating rate in the hope that uh rates
might start to calm down so if you went
back to sort of the tail end of the year
the beginning of this year
um you know a lot of the commentary
coming out of the bank of England the
out of the government was that inflation
was under control we were getting there
and of course that's proved not to be
the case and today's data proves that
further so we've now seen this shift of
mortgage rates going up and that's
forcing people into action you haven't
seen much evidence of people
remortgaging even though they don't have
to immediately is there much of that
going on I mean I think the moment that
people are just trying to find out what
the best thing for them is to do and so
and that's what we're saying to everyone
is get yourself into the most informed
position even if you're not coming to
the end of your mortgage rate right now
understanding what it would be like if
you were coming to the end of the rate
is is a good thing to be doing now the
treasury committee had uh various
lenders in front of them so I'm not sure
what they were trying to find out I mean
they I know there's an argument about
savings rates not being passed on as
rapidly as they could be but with
mortgages the lenders have no choice no
they don't and actually the margins that
they usually have to play with have been
eroded and there's really very little
margin in a mortgage right now for a
lender yeah absolutely uh where are you
seeing most people Plumping for them
when they're when they're going for
another fix
two-year fixes by far the most popular
for those that accept where the rates
are I think there's still a view that
even though we're not where we wanted to
be this is a 12-month problem an
18-month problem and then by the end of
the two-year rate that they come off the
mortgage Market might be looking a bit a
bit more promising yeah so to your fix
is the best and in the meantime though
we are seeing fewer products available
on the market I mean every day lenders
seem to be pulling products at what
point do you become worried about the
sort of scarcity in in terms of
availability I mean it's it's a constant
battle trying to keep up to date with
the market and you know for for a normal
borrower on the High Street it's a very
challenging place
um mortgage brokers are struggling with
it too as well it's a very fast-moving
Market
um in terms of where we think
um the number of products are going I
think we could see a few more reductions
in the number of products over the next
month or two really and particularly at
the higher loan to value mortgages which
of course has an impact on first-time
buyers well you've kind of preempted my
next question because uh I mean all the
the lenders say to me we've got plenty
of credit available we're still prepared
to learn we're looking to do business
are you seeing evidence of lenders
tightening their criteria not so much
typing their criteria but they're
looking at the pricing and the
availability of particularly those
higher loans of value products if you're
looking at the property Market you might
be thinking there's going to be a
correction we're already seeing house
prices step back in certain Regional
areas and overall the data shows a
decline so if you're a lender and you're
looking at lending 95 percent that's
potentially a risk yeah absolutely and
that's reflecting in the number of
products I mean it seems that uh buy to
let mortgages there is a bit of an
availability situation here definitely I
mean buy to let mortgages have been
really tough since the mini budget the
way that they're calculated the way that
lenders assess how much you can afford
against the rent of the property that
you've got with the interest rates the
way they are I mean you it's very
difficult to remortgage
I know I know your uh a mortgage broker
and advisor rather than a an estate
agent or anything like that but I mean
this is presumably going to have an
impact on on house prices at some point
well I think what we're seeing in the
property market right now is there's the
needs based people acting so those who
have to sell for whatever their reasons
are family reasons death divorce all
those sort of things and then there's
potentially a more an opportunistic uh
element to it as well where people who
have the means to buy are actually
listening to look for a bargain right so
you're seeing cash buyers out there then
there are still cash buyers out there
yeah right and it's an interesting place
to watch Simon good Olivia there good to
see you this afternoon thank you
foreign
[Music]
well the pound Rose to a 15-month high
against the US dollar after the wage
inflation figures dropped at seven
o'clock this morning Sterling has held
on to much of those gains it's a quarter
of one percent higher right now against
the Greenback 1.29 or so it's also up by
nearly two-fifths of one percent against
the Euro The single currency meanwhile
is off a tenth of one percent right now
against the dollar on the equity markets
well I can tell you uh the markets in
Europe have closed they've all finished
in positive territory I don't know
whether we can show you the prices there
here they all are so all of the main
Continental European indices in positive
territory not so uh prettier picture for
the ftse 100 this afternoon though uh
there we go finish where's look at that
it's finished uh nearly a tenth of one
percent higher or so a lot of those big
foreign currency uh earners have been
weighing on the index the healthcare
stocks in particular uh so a bit of a
comeback there from the foots he's been
in negative territory for most of the
session and in terms of individual
gainers there aren't very many in the
ftse 100 outside the footsie there's an
awful lot more going on the uh car parts
maker Dao lace is off some five and a
half percent on broker common that was
of course recently spun off from Melrose
Industries meanwhile pen on the group
the owner of Southwest water it Shares
are off by just over one percent that's
on news that it's paying 85 million
pounds for three new renewable energy
generation projects and then stocks
trading to the upside this afternoon
when the house Builder Gala for try look
at that it's up nearly seven and three
quarter percent that was following the
trading update earlier on this morning
on Wall Street I can tell you the S P
500 the NASDAQ and the Dow have all
opened higher this afternoon talking
point so you can see Microsoft on the
screen right now it's trying to buy the
games publisher Activision Blizzard and
it Shares are up some four and a half
percent that is after a U.S judge denied
a red Crest from the competition
regulator there the FTC to Halt its
takeover by Microsoft so Microsoft off
by uh two-thirds of one percent there
Activision Blizzard more than four and a
half percent higher right now very very
dramatic development indeed uh
concerning that very long-running
takeover situation as for the oil price
well that edged higher earlier on this
morning it's been trading in a pretty
tight range all day when it's broken out
this afternoon Battle of Brent group
will currently set you back
79.43 a barrel that is ahead some two
and a quarter percent will for joining
me this afternoon is the chief
investment officer for Charles Stanley
that's Patrick Farrell Patrick good to
see you this afternoon what's what's
been catching your eye today on the
markets and not been many individual
features to get excited about
well I I think Ian we we've seen some of
the more stimulus plans coming out of
China earlier on this morning and that
got the market off on a pretty good
start but the pay numbers as you
mentioned in the UK just continue to
surprise on the upside and the bank of
England certainly has some work to do
because what we're seeing is you know
there's just too much momentum behind
some of the wage data that's coming
through and how that's feeding through
into the inflation numbers so yeah the
strong Sterling is very much as a result
of you know some of the policy
expectations and where Peak rates are
actually going to end up in the UK but
on the flip side you know we had some
Consumer Credit numbers come through
from the US last night and they were a
lot weaker so there's a there's a double
whammy effect in terms of the currency
because the US dollar has really come
off on the back of hopefully that some
of the policy initiatives are actually
starting to slow consumer activity in
the U.S
and Patrick of course the the real show
stopper data Rises the inflation numbers
we get out of the us tomorrow
and I think what we can expect is we've
got a really big June 2022 number that's
going to drop out of the series so the
actual headline rate should actually
print in the low threes
and a lot of questions that I get is is
the job done for the fed you know being
in that sort of three percent sort of
range maybe the FED don't need to do too
much more
um but the unfortunate thing is for the
next six months we've still got some
very low numbers that are going to drop
out of the series so unfortunately the
inflation rate the headline rate at
least is going to pop back up again so
it's not all good news at this point but
it's certainly going to be a win from a
market perspective when we're looking at
the number tonight if I've understood
you correctly Patrick you're saying that
even if we get a low print tomorrow the
the FED definitely can't declare mission
accomplished yet
I don't think I don't think they can I
think that the core inflation rate is
still too high for their liking and they
continue to represent their inflation
Target at two percent
so even running at three percent and if
it pops back up to three and a half
later on towards uh the second half of
the year
it's still going to represent a number
that's too high for the Fed so I do
think that there is going to be more
interest rate hikes coming down to the
pipeline and I do think that the FED
will continue to talk tough in relation
to some of the sort of rhetoric that
they've been putting out
yeah and in the meantime Patrick worth
noting that moving the oil price this
afternoon was quite dramatic I mean
Brent crude nudging back towards 80
bucks a barrel it's been fairly quiet on
the oil front lately but it's a bit
disquieting to see it back at these sort
of levels
well it's one of the key things that
helped inflation come down so quickly
particularly in the US not so much here
but Energy prices and fuel prices in
particular are below where they were at
the start of the Ukraine war so that's
been a detractor from inflation and
that's pretty much the case right around
the major Market
but what we need to be a little bit
cautious about is if there is a
re-acceleration in oil prices that's
going to that's going to unwind some of
the detractions so it's been one of the
key mechanisms to actually have some of
this disinflation that we've been seeing
not in the UK but certainly in other
parts of the world
but if it starts to re-accelerate that
becomes a bit more of a problem for a
lot of the central banks around the
world
all right Patrick we have to leave it
there I'm afraid good to talk to you
this afternoon thanks very much indeed
for joining me thanks very much
that's it from me I'm back again with
business live tomorrow morning at 11 30
on Sky News 2. hope you can tune in for
that thanks for joining me today cheerio
[Music]